another 20/20 Democrat drops out of the
race and that candidate's failure says a
lot about the Democrats present dilemma
we will examine the fallout as another
one bites the dust
speaking of which an explosive new book
sheds new light on who Jeffrey Epstein
was and how he died and if he died we
will get to that the book just came out
yesterday I've read it and it is pretty
wild then a transgender woman which
means a man demands a gynecologist
inspect the genitals that he doesn't
have we will analyze why that matters
and Hong Kong protesters find hope in
swoll Trump all that and more I'm
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Nolt show
[Music]
swoll Donald Trump an image of Rocky
Balboa with Donald Trump's face is a
symbol of freedom and hope around the
world what a great timeline we are all
living in could you imagine a better
timeline I can't but on that point on
2020 I'm the leader of the free world
and I hope for the future in the hope
for 2020 another one bites the dust
you've probably already seen this going
around the internet Kamala Harris is
officially out of the race you know it's
not significant
in terms of the actual election no one
thought that Kamala Harris was going to
be able to claw her way out of the 2% in
the polls that she had but it does say
something about the state of the
Democratic Party right now the fact that
her candidacy flopped her candidacy
which looked very good on paper flopped
tells you a lot about where we are why
did the candidacy look good on paper
because the left is obsessed with
identity politics racial identity and
sexual identity politics obviously
Kamala Harris checks those boxes the
left is obsessed with unfettered
immigration Kamala Harris is the child
of immigrants the in terms of
presidential appeal in terms of how
these races tend to work if you've been
on the scene too long generally that
doesn't bode well for you especially in
the Democratic Party now think of Barack
Obama right Barack Obama goes up against
Hillary Clinton
we all knew Hillary forever she'd been
around since the dawn of time she was
around st. Petersburg when she felt it
was time for a change
so they knew what they were getting in
her Barack Obama very little was known
about him and and that actually helped
him he was a better candidate because
people didn't know that much about him
they could project their hopes and
dreams onto him hope and change was the
big theme of that campaign same thing
was true of Kamala Harris people didn't
really know who she was she was an
attractive looking candidate she sounded
pretty good when she wasn't giving that
awful cackling laugh she had been in
attorney general she had been a
prosecutor she had been a senator for
about five minutes everything looked
good about her campaign except
ideologically except ideologically
because Kamala Harris couldn't pick a
Lane and this this could be the name of
the 2020 Democratic primary is can you
pick a lane the pick a lane primary no
one's able to do it they're all veering
left they're all veering center Liz Ward
is she going to be a kind of
establishment Harvard professor or is
she gonna be this radical leftist trying
to go to the left of Bernie Sanders
mayor Pete is mayor Pete gonna be this
radical person saying that if you don't
support abortion and gay marriage you're
not a Christian or is he gonna be the
moderate guy in Joe Biden slain geo
Biden himself who is the moderate in the
race is Joe Biden gonna lean into being
a moderate or is he going to support
lifting the ban on taxpayer funding for
abortion that's the trouble with this
race and one thing we're seeing is it
doesn't hurt you to be in either of
those lanes when Joe Biden is playing
the moderate he generally does pretty
well when Bernie Sanders is playing the
leftist he generally does pretty well
but when you start to veer left and
center and left and center that's when
you fall apart and that's what happened
to Kamala Harris Kamala Harris lost
because of her own weaknesses she also
lost because Tulsi Gabbard absolutely
shanked her during one of the Democratic
debates you can almost pinpoint there
there are two moments I think that you
can pinpoint when Kamala Harris's
campaign completely fell apart
one of them at the hands of Tulsi
Gabbard on CNN senator Harris says she's
proud of her record as a prosecutor and
that she'll be a prosecutor president
but I'm deeply concerned about this
record there are too many examples to
cite but she put over 1,500 people in
jail for marijuana violations and then
laughed about it when she was asked if
she ever smoked marijuana
[Applause]
have freed an innocent man from death
row until the courts forced her to do so
she kept people in prison beyond their
sentences to use them as cheap labor for
the state of California and she fought
to keep bail system in place that
impacts poor people in the worst kind of
way when you are in a position to make a
difference and an impact in these
people's lives you did not and worse yet
in the case of those who were on death
row innocent people you actually blocked
evidence from being revealed that would
have freed them until you were forced to
do so there is no excuse for that
and the people who suffered under your
reign as prosecutor oh you owe them an
apology
tulsi stop it stuff at Tulsi she's
already dead so this was the attack the
attack on Kamala was comel as a cop
Camilla's too tough on crime Kamala was
throwing people into the prison system
that was the attack from the left which
is funny that it's made by Telsey
Gabbard who is ostensibly more to the
right of the Democratic Party on a
number of issues that was the hit that
they were putting on Kamala it worked
very well because Kamala played her
whole campaign as though she's going to
prosecute the case against Donald Trump
right
she's the tough prosecutor she's the
serious candidate she's she's not one of
these hippie-dippie candidates she's
gonna be really tough and what Tulsi
Gabbard did is she didn't go for
Camilla's weaknesses exactly she went
for her strengths Camilla's running I'm
the ex Attorney General I had a good
career as a prosecutor and Tulsi goes
for that strength now if Camilla were a
smart candidate she would have leaned
into that she would have said yet damn
right I put criminals in jail and I'm
gonna put the biggest criminal in
America who's sitting in the White House
whose name is Donald Trump I'm gonna put
that guy in jail he would have it would
have kind of done what Donald Trump did
in 2016 right Donald Trump in 2016 when
Hillary Clinton said I don't want to
live in an America where you're
president Trump said yeah that's cuz
you'd be in jail because leaning right
into it
that's what Kamala Harris should have
done instead she didn't she goes on The
Breakfast Club this popular radio show
and talks about how much he loves
smoking joints and blunts and listening
to Snoop Dogg we'll get all to that in a
second first I got
thank our friends over at bowl and
branch you know me I need to sleep about
I don't know 21 22 hours a day
I pretty much I go I kind of get out of
my luxurious nice bed with all my
bedding and I come and do this show and
I go right back into it it's very
important most people spend about one
third of their lives sleeping make sure
that you've got the best betting
everything Bowl and branch makes from
bedding to blankets is made from pure
100% organic cotton which means they
start out super soft and they get even
softer over time buying directly from
Boleyn branch means there's no middleman
you're basically paying wholesale prices
one thing I didn't know until I was
registering for my wedding luxury
bedding can cost a lot of money just
luxury sheets can cost up to $1,000 in
the store okay and luxury sheets are
amazing
I'm all for treating yourself on these
little things it seems like a little
thing right you know sheets who even
thinks about sheets especially men men
don't think about sheets but it makes
such a difference it feels so good when
you have those really really high
quality sheets well what if you don't
have to spend a thousand dollars on it
what if through Boleyn branch you can
get those sheets for just a couple
hundred bucks everyone who tries Boleyn
branch sheets loves them including me
especially me that is why Boleyn branch
has thousands of five-star reviews
shipping is free you can try them for 30
nights makes a great Christmas present I
gave a set of these to my in-laws and
won me a whole lot of points so highly
recommended if you don't love Boleyn
branch send them back for a refund but
you're not gonna want to send them back
no risk no reason not to give them a try
to get started right now my listeners
get Merry Christmas Christmas coming
early you get $50 off your first set of
sheets at Boleyn branch dot-com promo
code Michael mi CH AE L that is bol L
and branch comm for $50 off your first
set of sheets Bo LLM branch comm
promoted Michael Boleyn branch comm
promo code Michael so Camilla gets this
hit right this is the main attack
against her campaign your
you're a cop you're a prosecutor you're
throwing people into prison instead of
leaning into that doubling down and
saying damn right that's my campaign I'm
gonna prosecute Donald Trump I'm gonna
restore some order and sensibility to
America instead of doing that kampala
lanes in the other direction and
pretends that she's some big pothead
when she goes on a radio show I do has
anybody ever talked about smoking pot in
a more calculated and less believable
manner
hey you so commonly you ever smoke pot
yes yes that's right yes I yes I have
smoked the ganja the old Haitian oregano
you betcha that Peruvian parsley yes I
smoked it okay would you did you smoke a
blunt did you smoke a bowl did you smoke
a bong did you smoke a joint oh yeah I
had a joint is that right yeah joint I
smoked those jazz cigarettes out in
downtown Manhattan yes I did I know I
don't
I actually don't even believe she smoked
a joint just the way she's talking about
it's uh calculated it's so unbelievable
and then the joke and I did inhale
you're supposed to inhale marijuana
right yeah okay I inhaled that I just
don't buy it and then the story gets
even less credible when they ask her at
the end well when you're when you're
smoking all that pot that you allegedly
used to smoke you know what kind of
music were you listening to even that
doesn't sound believable
what does Carmela harris listen to him
listen to when you was high to pasture
yeah definitely I definitely commonly
you you when you were two minute
to use Barack Obama's word you were
listening to snoop and Tupac and by the
way calm Allah when did you smoke it
okay she said she smoked pot during
college she graduated college in 1986 I
believe it was years before snoop or
Tupac ever released their first album
it's that's actually a lie now do you
want to know what I actually think
Camilla Harris did during college I
think she studied because she's
obviously a type-a personality she is
ruthlessly ambitious ask Willie Brown
I'll just leave it at that she wants to
get ahead in her career I don't know
that she's ever smoked pot even once in
her life even to try it which is fine I
wish her answer to this question did you
ever smoke pot like I know cuz I'm not a
degenerate no I haven't smoked pot even
though virtually every young American
has I think they would have respected
that answer at least that's an that's it
there are these two kind of candidates
right candidates who are just trying to
pander to you who want to make you
believe that you're exactly like them
and they're exactly like you that's what
Kamala Harris is trying to do or their
candidates like Donald Trump who says
yeah I'm pretty much nothing like you
I'm a billionaire playboy I've never had
a drink in my life I've never had a beer
not even once and yet because of that
honesty because of that bluntness people
feel that they have more in common with
Donald Trump because he talks like a
real human being he's not just every
time he's asked a question he's not just
trying to think hmm what's the way that
I'll be most relatable to the person
that I'm talking to in this specific
audience he doesn't do that and that's
so it's much more believable if they had
said hey camelid you ever smoke pot she
doesn't know I I enjoy Chardonnay that
that's my drug of choice is Chardonnay
yeah who do you listen to when you're
when you're drinking Chardonnay I listen
to Brahms and hide him and Bach because
I'm better than you and I'm smarter than
you
I study more than you do and I have
wanted to be a lawyer and a politician
since the day I was born and that's who
I am
people would have respected that a lot
more she was disingenuous she was not
believable she didn't stand for anything
okay this this gets back to advice I
think
I forget if it was president george w
bush was some some people from the bush
era would would regularly bring this up
even when they were talking about say
the iraq war for instance and all the
problems that came with the Iraq war and
the point is sometimes a wrong decision
is better than indecision people can
respect a wrong decision
people can respect a difference what
they can't respect is waffling and
wavering and pandering Rudy Giuliani I
remember when he lost the 2008
presidential race was when he was asked
if he was rooting for the the Red Sox in
the World Series and he said he was
rooting for the Red Sox Rudy Giuliani a
lifelong Yankee fan mayor of New York
mayor of New York during 9/11 he said he
was rooting for the Red Sox and then he
came up with this convoluted logic he
said because I'm an American League fan
no you're not if you're a Yankee fan you
know what your favorite baseball team is
the Yankees you know what your second
favorite baseball team is any team that
can beat the Boston Red Sox simple as
that
Heath what he thought he was gonna lose
all the Massachusetts voters because he
doesn't like the Red Sox they know he
doesn't like the Red Sox he's a Yankee
fan they can respect that you can
respect a difference you can respect a
firm position that someone's holding how
many times do you hear this about Donald
Trump your people say I don't really
agree with Trump on this this amiss but
I like that he's honest I like that he's
blunt I like that he tells me what he
thinks Tom let didn't learn that lesson
there are other there are other
Democratic candidates who have not
learned that lesson either we'll get to
that a little bit later but now that
Kamala has bitten the dust we have got
to get to another man who bit the dust
Jeffrey Epstein there is a bombshell new
book it just came out yesterday
it's called Epstein dead men tell no
tales this was in pardon me I'm so
excited about this and I'm also a little
nervous that the more I talk about this
this episode or this this book rather
that the Hillary Clinton is going to
knock down the door and cost me to
commit suicide but it came out yesterday
really good reporters I think I might be
the only person that's actually read the
book so far I read the whole thing
yesterday I couldn't put it down there
is a lot of new information in this book
and
it goes a lot further around some of the
information that we've heard himself
we'll get to that in a second we will
find out perhaps once and for all the
likelihood that Jeffrey Epstein killed
himself and if if he did kill himself
then who who suicided him we'll get to
that in a second first I got to thank
our friends over at liquid ivy you might
be surprised to hear this but a lot of
people end up more dehydrated during the
winter months
cold weather tends to make us more
likely to miss the signs of dehydration
and less likely to keep refilling our
water bottles and also people go out
really late on New Year's Eve and you
know what happens
liquid ivy has the easy healthy fix for
winter dehydration many winter sports
take place at high altitude where it's
much easier to get dehydrated liquid ivy
is the perfect way to stay hydrated on
the mountain so liquid ivy has a lot of
great uses one if you just don't drink a
lot of water and you want to stay
hydrated and you want to do that in an
easier and more efficient way like what
IV is great for that if you're an
athlete liquid IV is obviously great for
that because it just replenishes you
it's much easier to hydrate you might
have guessed I'm not a huge Ashley I
don't go out on skiing expeditions or
anything like that but I do like the
occasional adult beverage you know a
nice glass of scotch or port and if you
go out with the boys you have one too
many you can wake up with a hangover I
find that liquid IV is just a lovely
little drink to have at the end of the
night it really helps to hydrate you so
if you're an athlete it's good for you
or if you're a derelict it's good for
you too like what IV is the
fastest-growing wellness brand you can
find them everywhere even Costco you can
find their hydration multiplier sold at
all Costco's nationwide
liquid IV can provide the same hydration
as drinking two to three bottles of
water it's a healthy alternative to
traditional sugary sports drinks there's
no artificial flavors there's no
preservatives like Pedialyte or Gatorade
liquid IV fuels you through workouts it
helps prevent muscle fatigue it promotes
healthy post-workout recovery I love it
I know that you will love it too the
christmas party season is upon us be
proactive about this my friends
you know if you're skiing or doing
winter sports right now my listeners get
25% off at liquid IV dot-com when you
use my promo code Knowles Canada wles
at checkout that is 25% off anything
anything you order on liquid Ivy's
website go to liquid IV dot-com and
enter my promo code Knowles canna wles
to get your savings and start getting
better hydration liquid IV dot-com promo
code Knowles canna wles do not wait
start properly hydrated today this book
actually something of a bombshell
Epstein dead men tell no tales it's
written by three investigative
journalists Dylan Howard Melissa Cronin
and James Robertson it's important to
note the author's because these aren't
just total Kooks these are pretty
well-known Hollywood Reporter's Dylan
Howard has been a huge investigator for
for us tabloids and show business papers
Us Weekly National Enquirer star in
touch ad we called him the king of
Hollywood scoops this guy broke the
story of Mel Gibson's audio tapes
screaming at his girlfriend he broke the
governador love child
Schwarzenegger skid he broke a lot of
Anthony Weiner stories the Tiger Woods
sex scandal that Charlie being Charlie
Sheen has HIV he's a big deal and he's
got a pretty good track record
I'm Melissa Cronin is another major
tabloid reporter and a Harvard Graduate
and Robertson James Robertson broke the
story of Epstein's first suicide attempt
they these guys have been investigating
Jeffrey Epstein for eight years they've
now put out their book for some reason
no one no one really has read it I
haven't seen a whole lot of coverage of
this book yet so far probably just
because it just came out yesterday a lot
of salacious details and it does offer
some some suggestions on big questions
the biggest claim in the book is with
regard to Jeffrey Epstein identity who
is this guy
how'd he get his money who was he
working for was he working for anybody
was there something bigger going on here
than just a wealthy guy running a sex
ring the biggest claim in the book
strongly suggested by the book he
that Jeffrey Epstein and Ghislaine
Maxwell were working for an intelligence
service it was a foreign entity it was
Mossad the Israeli intelligence
apparatus that is probably the most
consistently suggested point read the
whole book what's the evidence for it
well Ghislaine Maxwell who was Jeffrey
Epstein's Madame her father Robert
Maxwell almost certainly worked for
Mossad Rafi Eitan who's a famous Mossad
agent says them that Robert Maxwell
worked for Mossad other people have
backed that up the British Foreign
Office believed that Robert Maxwell was
a foreign spy re-bend Menashe is a
former Israeli spy who says he was the
alleged handler of Robert Maxwell says
the Maxwell introduced Epstein to Mossad
how did this happen Epstein and ghyslain
Maxwell took a shine to one another
early on Robert Maxwell then allegedly
introduced Jeffrey Epstein to Mossad
this is not to say that Jeffrey Epstein
was a spy in the traditional sense that
he was you know a trained career spy
actually what the investigators claim is
that Epstein and Maxwell weren't
terribly competent they weren't James
Bond exactly but they were very very
good at socializing that Epstein had
this absolute sixth sense for
ingratiating himself to people for
understanding social cues and that he
could just rise through the ranks of any
social circle so because of that they
were very good at blackmailing American
politicians and politicians from around
the world
Maxwell also had connections this is
Robert Maxwell to the khashoggi family
now if that name rings a bell that's
because the journalist according to the
mainstream media in America really known
as the Saudi insider Jamal Khashoggi was
killed by Mohammed bin Salman in Turkey
just last year it was yeah I was 2018
Jamal khashoggi who the the West is
presenting as this fearless journalist
who was really a part of a well-known
family in Saudi Arabia and
and worked with the Saudi regime Robert
Maxwell had connections to Adnan
Khashoggi
who was obviously very connected to
Saudi intelligence apparently the the
Maxwells introduced Epstein to khashoggi
then Epstein's working with Adnan
Khashoggi
who was a major figure in the
iran-contra scandal in the United States
during the Reagan administration when
the United States was selling arms
around the world Epstein was working
with Adnan Khashoggi to basically broker
these arms deals okay so he's already
got these connections you see two
different intelligence networks not just
necessarily Israel but also the United
States because the CIA was involved with
Khashoggi as well we know that Jeffrey
Epstein was running a blackmail ring he
had cameras fitted out on all of his
properties and they weren't cameras like
you see it a at a grocery store the
cameras sticking out of the wall these
were hidden cameras they were in clocks
they were in parts of desks they were
very very well hidden this was gathering
tons of information on high-level
politicians not just in the US but
around the world
we know that Epstein is connected to the
CIA we know he's connected to mi6 the
British intelligence apparatus we know
is correct it connected to Saudi Arabia
he had a Australian or an Austrian
passport rather that listed him as a
Saudi resident we know that he used that
passport to get into the United Kingdom
and to get into Saudi Arabia who gave
him the passport obviously was some
intelligence service
Epstein then in the 80s and 90s boasted
that he was connected to the CIA he was
also connected to the CIA because after
dropping out of college he got a job at
the Dalton School a very prestigious
private school that had was being run
and the headmaster had just retired but
he was still very involved by Donald
Barr who worked with the CIA and if the
name bar sounds familiar it's because
Barr is the father of the current US
Attorney General William Barr lots of
weird connections to intelligence here
how did that play out in Jeffrey Epstein
sweetheart
how did it play out in his death get to
that in a second but first speaking of
all this ancient history all of these
various connections between people you
should go check out ancestry you now
much I love ancestry and I've been using
ancestry since before we had a show
since before the Daily wire existed
ancestry lets you trace your family tree
it lets you see all the cool people in
your lineage ancestry when you just spit
in the tubes send it in it tells you all
about your family's history by analyzing
your DNA can tell you even how your
family move threat certain parts of the
world but don't forget your genes aren't
just about you genes are something that
you share with the people who are
closest to you uncovering potential
health issues early can help empower you
with information so you and your family
can move toward a healthier future that
brings us to ancestry health from
ancestry ancestry health looks at a
carefully selected set and gives you
insights about how they could impact you
and your family ancestry health gives
you personalized health reports that are
easy to understand
you get actionable insights this is the
key they're not going to tell you about
things that you can't do anything about
because that I wouldn't seem enjoyable
they'll give you information about what
you can act on that's access to genetic
counseling resources family health
history family health history that
allows you to track generations of
health and of course you'll also receive
ancestry DNA ethnicity results that
reveal your origins
I love the service I've used them for
years learn from your genes and take
action for your family go to
ancestry.com slash Knowles Skinner wles
to learn more and get your ancestry
health kit today that's ancestry.com
slash Knowles Canada wles ancestry
health includes laboratory tested ll
laboratory tests developed and performed
by an independent CLIA certified
laboratory partner and with oversight
from an independent clinician network of
board-certified physicians and genetic
counselors ancestry health is not
currently available in New York New
Jersey or Rhode Island but everywhere
else have a good time
so all of these connections to
National Intelligence apparently got
Jeffrey Epstein some pretty sweetheart
deals not just on the sex scandals that
came in the mid-2000s and obviously more
recently but even on financial scandals
so according to one of Epstein's ex
colleagues Steven Hoffenberg Epstein was
being investigated for financial crimes
at towers financial in the 90s the
people who were investigating him were
two of his closest friends and
confidants how did he hook that up he
happened to just be at this mastermind
criminal with a lot of information on
everybody so he gets investigated by two
people who were close to him this means
that Epstein's colleague Steven
Hoffenberg ends up in prison with a 1
million dollar fine 463 million dollars
in restitution 20 years in the clink
Epstein gets off scot-free by the way
right before his death Epstein put all
of his wealth into a trust that was
being controlled by the two men who
investigated him and let him off the
hook for these financial crimes in the
90s this raises the question in the book
is Epstein still alive
Epstein gets pinched for fraud and a
Ponzi scheme again Epstein gets off
scot-free he actually gets a sort of a
promotion because he ends up cleaning up
the finances of Lex less Wexner who's
the head of Victoria's Secret during
this time he then ends up renting an
apartment for $15,000 a month in New
York City but he doesn't have any money
how does he get the apartment guess who
his landlord is the State Department
during this whole time after Jeffrey
Epstein has been discovered to be this
criminal at least in the financial sense
he's renting an apartment from the state
department then les Wexner the head of
Victoria's Secret buys a major mansion
in New York the Herbert and Straus
mansion buys it for forty million bucks
it's the biggest private sale ever in
New York at the time he guts it he
installs cameras all over it he installs
a heated sidewalk then he just gives it
to Jeffrey Epstein there's no record of
any money changing hands during that
sale of the property the transaction was
never recorded in New York City records
online
another aspect of all this when the cops
finally raided Epstein's Palm Beach
house in 2006 they get there and
everybody was totally calm Epstein
wasn't on the property at the time
everyone's totally calm because the
house had already been cleaned out all
those records that they were looking for
already gone someone had tipped him off
he obviously had connections to law
enforcement
the investigators write that Epstein's
lawyers knew about details of the cop
investigation ahead of time he gets the
sweetheart deal from the federal
government because Alex Acosta then US
Attorney ended up being labor secretary
for Trump went over the head of the
investigators to the DOJ got the case
dropped even the way it was reported in
the press at the time the New York Times
gave a very fluffy report said though
it's you know not a big deal the
reporter who wrote that land in Thomas
junior went so easy on Trump Iran on
Jeffrey Epstein will get to help
students connected to Trump in a second
he then got a thirty thousand dollar
donation from Epstein to a preferred
charity of his and then ultimately left
the New York Times under a cloud of
controversy Jeffrey Epstein knew
freaking everybody he knew everybody the
flight log this is where Trump comes in
the flight logs on his plane the Lolita
express include Kevin Spacey Ralph's
fiends David Blaine Courtney Love Jimmy
Buffett Charlie Rose bill Wallace Bill
Gates Tony Blair a hood Barak former
Prime Minister of Israel David Koch the
zillionaire conservative libertarian
funder Bill Clinton former President of
the United States you might recall Bill
Clinton who would flew on that plane
twenty-seven times even though he denied
it Bill Clinton who went with his wife
and stayed at Epstein's properties in
New Mexico and to Donald Trump except
Donald Trump
there's not a lot of evidence they flew
on the lolita Express plane
interestingly of all these very powerful
men the Epstein accusers say they saw
Trump a number of times but they never
saw Trump engage in the sexual
activities even Virginia Roberts who's
the main accuser against Epstein she
says yeah I saw Donald Trump but I never
saw him engage in any of the weird sex
stuff
but f Steen was close to so many other
people Mohammed bin Salman who's running
Saudi Arabia who ordered the killing of
Jamal khashoggi who's the nephew of
Adnan Khashoggi when when Jeffrey
Epstein got released from his sweetheart
jail sentence in Palm Beach
he had a welcome home party attended by
Prince Andrew Charlie Rose Katie Couric
Chelsea Handler the comedian Woody Allen
and George Stephanopoulos who's the
chief political anchor over at ABC and
who was the communications director for
Bill Clinton all of these guys so
connected him Prince Andrew according to
this reporting way more involved than
anybody had previously thought and then
you get to the weirdest matter of all
which is all the mysterious deaths that
occurred just around the time of Epstein
getting pinched and Epstein's alleged
suicide we'll get to that in a second
then we'll get to speaking of creepy sex
stuff Jessica you Neve the transgender
activist who is demanding that
Gynaecologists treat the genitals that
he does not have we will get to the
world's largest animal sacrifice we will
get to swole Trump all of that and more
but you must go to Daley wire com ten
bucks a month hundred dollars for an
annual membership you get me you get the
Andrew claim ensure you get the Ben
Shapiro sure you get the mount wall show
you get to ask questions in the mailbag
you get another Kingdom the final season
the best season highly recommended
because actually another Kingdom has a
lot to do with Hollywood and the creepy
weird sex stuff that goes on here and
how that's connected to international
leftism
and it's pretty much just about Jeffrey
Epstein
even though drew wrote the book before
Jeffrey Epstein was a big news story
truth is sometimes just as true as
fiction and fiction is just as true as
nonfiction and you get the leftist
here's tumblr you need the leftist tears
tumblr especially is 2020 heats up head
on over to daily wire calm we will be
right back with a lot more
just one last note on Jeffrey Epstein
and what it might mean for his alleged
suicide there were was not just the
death of Jeffrey Epstein when we saw the
death of Jeffrey Epstein there were a
lot of other people who were close to
Epstein who died around that time so
Epstein who was terrified that he was
going to be assassinated this has gone
on for decades
he had his pilot's when his plane was
grounded drive out to Texas to armor
plate his car because he was so
convinced he was about to be killed the
guy who owned the company that Epstein's
chauffeur worked for you got to remember
fdn chauffeur is working pretty much
exclusively for him he died mysteriously
three days before Epstein died and the
people close to him say they have no
idea why he died in 2018 one of the Palm
Beach Sheriff guys well my guys on the
case
died suddenly at the age of 50 the age
of 50 very young man just when all this
Epstein stuff came about died of a very
sudden illness that came on quickly and
he was dead within six months around
that same time a house man for Jeffrey
Epstein who cleans Jeffrey Epstein
sextoys died of a similar illness a
six-month cancer at the young age of 60
at the same time one of the victims for
the plaintiffs or one of the lawyers for
the plaintiffs rather died of another
quick tack needing cancer at age 68 a
lot of weird deaths occurring around
Jeffrey Epstein at a very early age now
I'm not a conspiracy theorist guy I
always want the simplest answer to the
question some of these people might have
just died people die that happens but as
more and more of these coincidences
start to occur it's more of these
connections start to occur I mean the
connections between Jeffrey Epstein and
the intelligence services are undeniable
how do we know that because Alex Acosta
the US attorney on the case actually
said
that they reduced the punishment for
Jeffrey Epstein because he's above my
paygrade quote he belongs to
intelligence the Jeffrey Epstein was
operating an international blackmail
ring all of that seems to suggest not a
conspiracy theory but an actual
conspiracy why does it matter why does
this book matter the book matters
because nobody's taking the case
seriously anymore I mean we joke about
I've been joking about it all the time
you know Jeffrey Epstein didn't kill
himself that became a meme people would
add it to normal everyday quotidian
conversation and then they'd end with
this non sequitur and Jeffrey Epstein
didn't kill himself and we all laugh
about it
we are laughing about it sure because
it's so funny but no one's talking about
Jeffrey Epstein anymore the guy ran the
most notorious sex ring certainly in
modern memory may be in an even longer
memory it involved heads of state it
involved some of the biggest names in
finance technology business diplomacy it
involved royalty
Prince Andrew deeply involved in this
and we're all just letting it go that's
it Jeffrey Epstein dies under suspicious
circumstances look he very well might
have killed himself the fact that he was
allowed to kill himself is pretty weird
but let's just say he killed himself who
cares that's the least suspicious part
of the whole thing
why are we not looking into this anymore
why is nobody talking about this why is
it just a joke we have actually seen the
most powerful people in the world
connected to this guy to a underage sex
ring and by the way we're not just
talking about sixteen year olds here
we're talking about like twelve year
olds all right the evidence from that
just the birth dates of the people who
were at Jeffrey Epstein's various
compounds show that they were really
really young all right not just junior
or senior in high school young like
middle school young like even younger
and yet
just become a joke that shows you the
power of the people involved the very
fact that nobody will take it seriously
shows you the power of the people
involved and when we talk about from a
political angle say the deep state or
the mainstream media monopoly the
apparatus or big tech the monopolies
they have over information in your
information this is a really good way to
demonstrate that power this story which
is obviously lurid it has all these sex
details because the story just like
Jeffrey Epstein is going away it's
biting the dust it's going down the
memory hole this was a good first step
this book is good I highly recommend you
read it but obviously the book leave the
book gives a lot of answers it leaves
far more questions them answers we'll
have to leave it there with Jeffrey
Epstein because we have to talk about
more creepy sex stuff namely Jessica
yaniv the transgender activist who very
famously put immigrant beauty salon
workers out of business in Canada
because they refused to wax his genitals
he walks in to get a Brazilian wax this
is a procedure that can only be done on
women there is another thing called
demands Ileana let's not explain the
details but it's a different procedure
he goes in there he says he wants a
Brazilian wax on his male genitals they
say well that's not possible and also we
don't want to touch your genitals and he
sues them he doesn't sue they mean he
files a complaint which ends up putting
them at a business now he wants to shut
down a gynecologist for not operating on
or inspecting the genitals that he does
not have this is what he wrote quote so
gynecologist office that I got referred
to literally told me today that we don't
serve transgender patients and me being
shocked and confused and a hurt are they
allowed to do that legally isn't that
against the practices Gynaecologists
form a part of the multi multi
disciplinary team who engage with
transgender and non-binary patients
either as part of the transition stage
performing surgery or managing pre or
post gynecological problems
the Canadian Bureau has confirmed to me
that the refusal I've received is
discrimination under the BC Human Rights
Code I will file a complaint with you
today about that clinic okay at this
point I'm wondering is Jessica you Nev
just the Joker is he just this absolute
anarchist with an absurdist sense of
humor who wants to cause pain to people
I'm beginning to think that I mean you
Nev after he came to the attention of
everybody for shutting down these poor
beauticians businesses putting them out
at work he also tried to host a queer
kids party so a party that would be
topless for kids as young as 12 years
old that ended up not happening but he's
obviously a provocateur he's obviously
got a screw loose he was he was texting
young girls sexting them very
inappropriate conversations is he just
the Joker I actually kind of defend the
existence of someone like Jessica you
Nev because with Jessica you Nev is
doing is testing the boundaries of our
new revolutionary society he's testing
the boundaries of leftism are we gonna
put up with this is this the society
that we want to live in where you're
putting Gynaecologists out of work
because they won't operate on men's
genitals where you're putting female
beauticians out of work because they
won't perform a technically impossible
procedure on a man they won't fondle a
man's genitals is that the kind of
society that we want to live in that is
pretty barbaric stuff it gets to other
kinds of barbaric cultures you know our
culture is becoming more barbaric we're
getting a glimpse of other barbaric
cultures around the world there was the
world's largest animal sacrifice just
the other day in Nepal Hindu worshipers
have started beheading thousands of
buffalo in Nepal as part of the world's
largest animal sacrifice event it's
called the gadhimai festival started in
the early hours on Tuesday morning when
a priest killed a goat rat chicken Pig
and pigeon then cut himself open offered
blood from his own body there are around
200 butchers using these kukri nine
and came to this walled temple and
started to be had an estimated 3,500
Buffalo 3,500 you know they never tell
you about this part when you go to buy
the yoga mat there are a lot of web
people here in the West who really like
the idea of Eastern religion and Eastern
culture they never tell you the part
about slaughtering 3500 Buffalo with a
knife do they no they don't we can
recognize that as barbaric and yet in
our own culture we were attracted to
these sorts of things
we're attracted to primitivism we're
attracted to the idea of the noble
savage being one with nature
following your desires and your
appetites as though your desires and
appetites will simply lead you in a
proper direction rather than following
the traditional religion of the West
rather than following the traditional
moral order rather than restraining your
desires and your appetites rather than
recognizing mankind as a unity of body
and soul not merely metaphysical not
merely physical it's actually it's the
same story as the Jessica Yaniv story
it's the story of civilization as we
know it falling back to long discredited
religious views in the case of
transgenderism the idea that we are not
at all our bodies that we can butcher
and mutilate our bodies the idea that we
should just follow our desires to the
end no matter what pain that causes to
other people and in the case of this
animal sacrifice obviously the same
thing following a long discredited
religion a religious practice rather
this mass animal sacrifice because of
some kind of pantheistic or pagan
intuitions the human beings have that's
where we're headed that's when we're
throwing off the yoke of our own
traditional culture something's got to
replace that everybody's got to serve
somebody okay and when we follow the
left which simply wants to destroy the
left simply wants to tear down our
tradition the left simply wants to tear
down that which we want to conserve
that doesn't just leave you in a void
that doesn't just leave you floating in
space
something will fill that political ideas
cultural ideas religious ideas and the
left wants to pretend these are all new
ideas they're not they're the oldest
ideas in the world there's a reason we
discarded them in the first place
there's a reason why we developed the
civilization we have there's a reason
that we want to conserve it
maybe we should cling a little more
closely to that maybe we should try a
little harder to conserve that I mean
youyou see this all the way around the
world in Hong Kong in Hong Kong right
now you have the protests against the
Chinese government they've persisted for
six months they've turned violent now I
mean the Chinese government is clamping
down on them there is a new photo that
has emerged a new image that has emerged
for the Hong Kong protests it's an image
of Donald Trump's head on rocky Balboa's
body they're calling it swole Trump and
they are using this on ironically as the
image for the protest what does it mean
it means that the traditional image of
America is still a hope to those seeking
freedom from tyranny that's the
conservative image they wouldn't be
holding images of swoll Obama there's no
such thing it means that manliness is
still a virtue it's not toxic it's not
toxic like the left says it means that
eternal truths still hold it means that
the people who are protesting in Hong
Kong really protesting tyrannical
government they recognize the worth the
value of our civilization and our
culture that we're just throwing away to
the left you know Hong Kong was a
westernized city until the late 90s when
the British gave it back to China and
since then it's gotten worse and worse
each year these eternal truths though
still hold you know the left always
wants to convince conservatives that
modernity has totally changed
circumstances in human nature it hasn't
just listen there's a great guy on the
streets in Hong Kong who gave a very
simple message for the United States he
goes out there and he just says Trump
don't give in on China
China is a and then he uses a profane
word that I'm not going to use but he's
very simple though
given to China China or a bunch of jerks
is what you could say it's simple as
that they recognize the value of our
civilization we're throwing it away and
that doesn't just mean one politician is
going away one political candidates
going away one big news story one
international sex ring one major
political issue is going away it doesn't
mean that it means we could lose our
whole civilization if we don't pay
attention if we don't try to preserve
and conserve those things that have
allowed us to flourish for this long all
right we are we're done flourishing for
today we will flourish again tomorrow
tune in in the meantime I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Nolt show
I'll see you then
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boy
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens assistant director pavel white
house key
edited by Danny D'Amico audio is mixed
by Mike or Amina hair and makeup is by
Joshua alvera and our production
assistant is Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19 on the Matt
Walsh show we're not just discussing
politics we're talking culture faith
family all of the things that are really
important to you so come join the
conversation